who is satoshi nakamoto it's one of the
most important questions in the world
satoshi nakamoto's a pseudo-anonymous
person or group that created bitcoin the
decentralized digital currency obviously
satoshi has one of the largest fortunes
in the world and as bitcoin's price
continues to rise satoshi nakamoto is
likely going to become one of the
wealthiest people in the entire world
there are many people including myself
that believe satoshi should be nominated
for something like the nobel peace prize
for being able to bring new type of
money to the market but everyone wants
to know who is satoshi nakamoto one of
the things that's very important to
understand about bitcoin is that it
didn't just fall from the sky we have a
timeline that shows all of the back work
all the pre-work that went into actually
getting bitcoin launched and becoming
what it has become today
if you go all the way back to the 1970s
you can see on this timeline that
bitcoin is the recipient the beneficiary
of so much computer science work that
work includes things like the invention
of tcpip it includes things like the new
directions in cryptography in 1976 from
whitfield uh diffie it also includes
things like merkel uh coming out with
the protocols for public key crypto
systems it also includes things like
murray roth barge the ethics of liberty
so sometimes it is computer science it
is actually technical in nature and
other times it is simply things around
the ethos if you fast forward you can
start to see things like david shaw in
1983 coming out with the blind
signatures for untraceable payments if
you go all the way up and you look at
other attempts at digital currencies
digi cash in 1989 or cyber cash in 1994
e-gold in 1996 but including also things
like the creation of proof-of-work adam
back cash dos counter measure with proof
of work system in 1997. over and over
and over again we had multiple
increases in the potential of the
technology we continued to push the ball
forward including things like a
cypherpunk's manifesto in 1993 or
timothy c may the cryptonomic in 1994
but then eventually we got all the way
to things like bittorrent in 2001 hal
finney coming out in 2004 with reusable
proof of work and then eventually the
bitcoin white paper appear bitcoin
appear to pure electronic cash system in
october 31st 2008 and then we got the
launch in early january of 2009 where
bitcoin launched in that genesis block
having the message chancellor on the
brink of second bailouts for banks that
ultimately led to bitcoin being launched
to the public and more and more people
started to come in and creating a
decentralized digital currency that is
adopted by a hundred plus million people
around the world everyone from
individuals to corporations financial
institutions and now nation states using
this asset but who is satoshi nakamoto
well if we go back in history and we
look at all the people working on
digital currencies leading up to this we
can see there are many different people
who had a massive hand in actually
coming up with this type of technology
if we go ahead and we look at this list
here we can see that there are five main
people that are worth paying attention
to the first being david shaw the father
of the cypherpunk movement nick zaba who
proposed bitgold in 1998 and coined the
term smart contracts adam back
implementing proof of work in 1997
founded block stream in 2014 hal finney
who has unfortunately passed away has
received the first bitcoin transaction
in history from satoshi and wei dey
proposed b money which was an anonymous
distributed electronic cash system in
1998. nobody is claiming that one of
these five is satoshi but many of them
are rumored to either have played a big
hand or potentially could be satoshi
themselves and nixabo adam backed how
finney etc but ultimately satoshi
nakamoto is unknown it's a
pseudo-anonymous person or group the
fact that nobody knows is a huge
advantage if we knew who satoshi was
people would try to put that person in
place of bitcoin rather than look at the
idea rather than look at the technology
they would be looking at the person do
we like with the clothes that they wear
do we like their views on other things
do we like who they are what religion
where they come from their wealth status
etc but because we do not know who
satoshi nakamoto is nobody can attack
the creator it is simply an idea in fact
we are all satoshi satoshi is the
pursuit of freedom satoshi is the
pursuit of the individual sovereign and
that ultimately is the beauty of bitcoin
is that nobody knows who created it but
everyone can evaluate the idea and the
code for themselves and as more and more
people continue to go down the rabbit
hole and evaluate bitcoin they continue
to adopt the digital store of value we
now have over a trillion dollar asset
that was created by a pseudo anonymous
person or group
satoshi nakamoto one of the most
impactful people in the world but the
ultimate thing that satoshi did was not
create bitcoin but it was simply to walk
away and never reveal their identity